Kingsman the golden circle is once again
directed by Matthew Vaughn coming off of
his sequel Kingsman the Secret Service a
film that really surprised me took me
off-guard hadn't expected to be that
good it was really entertaining kind of
insane and really audacious and
in-your-face
and I liked pretty much everything about
it so naturally I was excited for
another journey into this world
Taron Egerton once again plays eggsy the
young recruits of the Kingsmen Secret
Service and this time around Julianne
Moore queen of the drug trade is holding
the world hostage having inserted a
terrible virus into virtually every
popular drug so the Kingsmen have to
team up with the statesmen of America
Jeff Bridges Channing Tatum Halle Berry
to go against Julianne Moore and her
Empire of virus inducing drugs so I mean
it sounds good right it's pretty crazy
it wouldn't make sense for me to go into
the sequel a Kingsman expecting
something that wasn't insane the first
movie was so over-the-top and enjoyably
so that I was hoping for a similar
experience the second time around but
this does suffer in some ways from
trying to put way too many things into
one movie sometimes a sequel tries to be
bigger and better so they go for a
better villain or more action sequences
or more special effects this film oddly
chooses to have so much more in regards
to the subplot area there are so many
different things that occur in this film
that take characters from point A to
point B with the goal of getting them
eventually to point Z and instead of
just having a logical reason to get to a
place they use all these convoluted
methods to get characters to go places
like they're trying to find a location
and so they have to go to this big
concert and two men have to try to
seduce a woman to get a tracker inside
her so that they can follow her to
wherever this base is and it's this big
elongated sequence that feels so
unnecessary and this film unfortunately
falls into mini scenes like that it's
very long it's like 2 hours and 21
minutes and when the action comes it's
exciting it's loud it's visually
appealing but so much of the in-between
stuff feels like baggage and the film
becomes kind of boring
times this was a disappointing movie for
me it has a lot of the things that I
liked about the first namely its
subversiveness it's a reverence but it
doesn't have anything that made it feel
fresh I like Julianne Moore quite a bit
as the villain she was giving a very fun
performance her character however and
the way the script uses her was strange
she is constantly separated from
everything she's at this jungle 1950s
diner style hideout that's not really a
hideout at all she's literally created
an oasis of 1950s nostalgia in the
middle of the jungle anybody could find
her she's surrounded this area by mines
she has robot dogs and a very famous
singer that has some of the funnier
parts in the movie at her disposal at
all times and they keep her there
through the entire film so her Menace is
entirely brought about by whoever
happened to do some drugs that maybe one
of our lead characters cares about who
could die from this virus and as a
villain she's very very weak and it's
often said that a movie is only as
strong as its antagonist and in this
case that's true she is giving a very
fun and likable performance and I
thought she was really good in the movie
but as a character she had no menace at
all and I just didn't find myself all
that concerned with our heroes this time
around
Taron Egerton is really good as eggsy
Colin Firth is great once again mark
Strong is really good channing tatum's
entertaining everyone's doing fine
there isn't like a weak link when it
comes to the performances you can tell
that everyone is really trying to make a
good movie and the biggest praise that I
can give this film is the cinematography
we'll talk about the cinematography in
the action sequences but aside from that
conversation scenes location photography
of sets and places they visit the one
perfect shot Twitter is going to have a
ball when this movie comes out on
blu-ray because it's really well shot
everything looks perfectly symmetrical
it's a really beautiful looking film
let's talk about those action sequences
while they are kind of visually
appealing this one went really far with
the using CGI to stitch shots together
to make it all look like one
can take and sometimes it can get very
jumpy and jittery and it just doesn't
feel like you're watching something
that's actually happening it feels like
you're watching this really cool video
game sequence that were set up to look
as impossibly entertaining as they could
make it but that's kind of the feeling I
got from so many of the action sequences
the first one as I said was super
over-the-top and it really went for that
this one I think suffers from having
just too much they're trying to do
they're really really going for like the
superhero II sequences that make no real
sense
we're like human beings our catapulting
all over the place and doing these
insane moves and it just kind of lost me
after a while I had fun with this movie
overall I don't think it's awful I think
that it is disappointing and that from a
story perspective they should have cut
out so much but the performances and the
overall fun vibe of the movie makes it
perfectly watchable it's just a
disappointment when you compare it to
the first one and like I said they
really should have cut out a lot I'm
gonna give Kingsman the Golden Circle a
see guys thank you so much as always for
watching I'm gonna have a ton of reviews
this weekend lots of catching up to do I
have friend requests
lego ninjago movie I want to see Brad
status I want to see stronger I have a
lot of stuff to do guys thank you very
much as always and if you like this you
can click right here and get to stuff my
nice
[Music]